[Music]
hey what's up guys it's marquez from the
mkbhd channel back with another hd video
and today we're going to be taking a
look at the top google plus tips and
tricks now that being said you can check
out my google plus link down in the
description g plus dot to mkbhd or you
can add me to whatever circle you want
without any further ado let's take a
look at our list of our top tricks the
first tip is going to be tagging with
the plus symbol you may have already
heard of being able to tag users in
posts or in pictures or especially in
posts on facebook with the at symbol you
can do this as well on twitter with the
app symbol and now with google plus you
can add a plus before someone's name and
of course it'll bring up a suggestions
box for who you want to tag and you can
tag someone in a post and i'll get a
notification about it tip number two is
the ability to edit and delete posts
actually you can do this after you post
them in google plus which is unlike
facebook or twitter you have to delete
and repost in google plus you can hit
that little drop down on the right hand
side of your post and you have the
ability to edit what you've already
posted or you can even disable resharing
on the spot you can also delete a post
if you feel you don't want to have it
there just like any other social network
but i think the ability to edit posts
really separates it makes it pretty
unique tip number three is native text
formatting you can't do this in facebook
or twitter either but in google plus you
can add certain characters before and
after text to give them a bold italic
underline or strikeout face i'll put all
these tips of course an annotation or in
the description of the video so of
course in the descriptions the whole
write up where you can see all these
things but of course if you check out my
google plus page you can probably
already find some formatted text there
number four is notifications and i think
google plus does notifications really
well and they're available in a wide
range of all your google services so no
matter whether you're in gmail or google
calendar or wherever you are in a google
service you'll have your notifications
up top and you can of course click that
drop down and view sort of a pain-like
scrolling effect where you can view all
your notifications tip number five is
having your photos everywhere of course
when you add a photo and upload it to a
post in google plus it'll create an
album for that picture where you can
have a whole bunch of different albums
with the posts with pictures in them you
can view these on all your google
devices that are synced with google plus
so you can see i have this on my
motorola zoom i have this on my phone
all the pictures that i've posted from
all my google plus posts are available
for me to see anywhere so that's pretty
cool number six is keyboard shortcuts
i'll also have these in the description
the keyboard shortcuts are pretty cool
they allow you to create new posts and
share new pictures and do things pretty
quickly these are for more of the power
users the people who are really using
google plus a lot that'll be able to
find these shortcuts really useful
number seven is the ability to send
personal messages now you can do this
via facebook and twitter and it might
have seemed a little bit obscured how to
do this in google plus so the
instructions on how to send personal
messages through google plus will be
below and also you can view a video
obviously you can just click the button
and send personal messages so that's
pretty cool that you have the ability to
do that last but not least is the
shortened link that i showed you earlier
in the video you can use a sort of a
vanity url since you don't feel like
using google plus.google.com and the
whole url things like that so g plus dot
to slash your username is what's
available you can use the service g plus
dot to which will be in the description
which will allow you to shorten your url
and send that profile to anyone this has
been a quick video about google plus
tips tricks hints shortcuts uh different
things you might not have known about
google plus or maybe you already knew
that i don't know but if you have any
other things you'd like to share about
google plus you can leave them in the
comments section below and be sure to
give this video a like it keeps the
series going and uh the next youtube
tips videos and forum friday is coming
up very soon so stay tuned for those and
if you're not already subscribed
be sure to do that above thanks for
watching guys i'll talk to you later
peace
[Music]
you